And three of these are rates.
In each of these I can identify
the two different quantities.
For example, dollars and
hours, babies and
years, and ounces of Coke and calories.
Which means I could write write these
rates as $12 divided by one hour,
four million babies divided by one year,
or two hundred sixty calories
divided by twenty ounces of coke.
And notice that the word and
here actually corresponded to per,
it actually meant division.
And also notice that over here,
even though ounces of Coke,
came first in the sentence, I decide to
put it in the denominator of my rate.
And will see that with rate we
have the freedom to decide which
quantity goes in the numerator and
which goes in denominator.
But we'll explore that
a little bit more later.